lentils are a staple food in India but
they're now beyond the reach of people
like prima the 47 year old works as a
maid in Delhi and has been hard hit by
the Indian government's abrupt move to
scrap commonly used currency notes
malaga by asked the vendor to give me
some lentils on credit since I just
don't have the cash but he refuses the
situation is really bad I'm slowly
running out of food at home many street
vendors have no bank account and can
only deal in cash initially shy about
speaking on camera street vendor
muhammad nasir tells us he feels
helpless I don't know what to do people
here have no money to buy my products so
I can't buy stock from the market either
it's the end of my business the sudden d
monetization of the 500 and 1000 rupee
notes has led to huge lines outside
banks and chaotic scenes in an economy
that's overwhelmingly cash driven for
days people have been rushing to
exchange old notes and get their hands
on the new currency Gotti the Molyneux
they have young children to feed at home
I just have to get some money today I've
been waiting for hours to get money it's
such a waste of time I have a lot of
other work to take care of yet the
Cathars causing a lot of inconvenience
for the people but it's only for a short
period in the long run I think it's a
very good reform others here in this
low-income neighborhood feel the same
despite the hardships Kramer's friend
Joe Goethe suffers from high blood
pressure and diabetes and cannot line up
to get money she says she hasn't been
able to buy her medicines for a week now
over Culloden the reform makes sense
because it's meant to fight corruption
and illegally obtained money but the
poor are suffering the most in the
process prima heads home hoping to get
some vegetables on credit later in the
afternoon she's worried that if things
continue this way the situation may
become desperate yeah audience will only
get better if the prices come down
everything is so expensive
and at the same time there's no money
it's causing a lot of problems if it
continues people like us will have to
start skipping meals bansal Primus still
has a wad of old currency notes at home
until a week ago that would have ensured
her a comfortable life now it's nothing
more than junk